- So only one hour and 20 whatever minutes
left to go, Daysha.
Sit real tight.
(electronic music)
- I've done teeth whitening
once with a white strip.
It didn't go well.
- I just imagine like this giant machine
is gonna like like this.
- I've actually been told
I have quite white teeth.
I actually wore my retainer
for the first time in months last night
in preparation for this.
- I'd like to think that
this is gonna be OK.
I mean it's just a guy
playing around in my mouth.
(beep)
Ryan, I can't with you
snickering. (laughs)
- Teeth become discolored due
to many different reasons.
It could be diet, you know.
Drinking too much wine, coke, or smoking.
The two kinds that we offer in our office.
We do a zoom whitening which is mostly
hydrogen peroxide in it.
Hydrogen peroxide is basically bleach.
You're smiling.
You're thinking like oh this is painful.
- Oh I'm glad I'm not doing that one.
- Then there's sensational
one that we use in our office.
Doesn't have any other kind of chemicals
to help accelerate that process
so it's a much smoother
process for the patient.
- How blinding is my smile gonna be?
Like that's what I want it to be.
- You're gonna be rocking over this.
So we're gonna start with two of you.
Who's gonna go first?
Do we know?
OK.
You have a cool room
back there for the boys.
- There's also a hover
board back there, right?
- There is.
- I'm gonna ride the shit
out of that hover board
while wearing that hat.
- So Maysie and I are both gonna be doing
the chemical process.
- I think my teeth are
already kind of white
but I'm pretty excited to
make them like super white.
- Yeah you look like
you're from the future.
How do you like it, Daysha?
We made it just for you.
- Just this looks relaxing.
I would love to do this at home
on a Saturday by myself.
- This looks relaxing to you?
- Yeah.
- [Daysha] Everybody keeps talking
about how it's about to hurt
so like I have no idea
what I'm really in for.
I can't imagine what would be doing
for an hour an a half.
- Shall I hover board with a viking helmet
or a pimp hat?
(laughter)
- This is great.
This is what I want every time
I come to the orthodontist.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Maysie] This first two like
phases was like totally fine.
I was relaxed.
Everything was great.
- I'm so scared.
Oh shit.
It's moving.
- I don't know what to do. (laughs)
- Put some glasses on.
- There was just a sharp, shooting pain
just on my bottom teeth.
(laughter)
- What happened?
- Just focus.
- OK, OK.
I'm good.
(laughter)
- Yes.
Yes.
- Dude, you're fucking.
Oh you're going to hit the exit sign.
(laughter)
Don't worry.
It'll all be over soon.
(blowing)
It'll be fine.
- Oh yeah minus the fact that
Ryan was trying to put his
nasty hot air in my face
everything else was great.
- So who's you're favorite friend?
(laughter)
(gibberish and laughter)
(humming)
That's the wrong answer.
(laughter)
(air sucking)
(indistinct talking)
- I'm gonna fuck you.
Oh my god.
(laughter) Bitch.
- The head of this lamp is
going to go right on top.
It's gonna beam you up.
- Wait so all you have to do
is just put that in their mouth?
Oh!
(laughter)
- Wait, wait.
Put the shades on.
It's always cool with shades.
- No chemicals.
Nothing unnatural.
This is all natural, baby.
(rock music)
- Wala.
30 minutes and we'll see
you on the other side.
- [Daysha] Yeah sleep with one eye open.
- I didn't realize like how much
of a discrepancy it was.
- Yeah.
(camera click)
(laughter)
- What are you looking at?
No one's going to help you.
I hope you know that.
No one's gonna help you.
Where's those sharpies at?
(humming)
Mhm.
Got anything to say?
Oh?
Nothing?
Ryan thought it was cute
to blow hot air in my face
so I think it would be cute
to give Ryan a little tattoo
because like I appreciate Ryan so much.
(laughter)
- Hold my hand.
Keep your mouth in the light, Ryan.
Don't mess it up.
(laughter)
- For the most part it wasn't that bad.
I felt it a little bit.
It was a little sensitive
but for the most part I don't think
my teeth are that sensitive.
Like it didn't really hurt.
- It would come in waves.
So I would be like fine
and then all of a sudden
it would just be like
this really intense pain.
- No aches, no pains, very quick.
I just had a weird little
gelatin thing in my mouth.
My jaw got kind of tired after a while
but that was it.
Very soothing, very relaxing.
It was basically just a nap.
- The treatment was great.
I just bit into a
mouthpiece like Steph Curry.
It was all over.
I never pictured myself having
you know a sons of anarchy style tattoo
of the word penis on my neck.
- We have like amazingly
white teeth right now.
So I also think that if you really want
super white teeth this
would be the way to go.
So it's like no pain, no gain.
Depends on how like committed
you are to having white teeth.
(laughter)
Essentially.